the escort Carter story Manuel Shaffer
presents the successor to the Skoda Yeti
the car rock he thinks the improved
design should appeal to a wider variety
of tastes now he'll see what else it has
to offer at first glance it could be
confused with a Skoda Kodiak but the new
car out is more than 30 centimeters
shorter than its big brother and more
than 200 kilograms lighter with a curb
weight of just one and a half tons and
the family resemblance doesn't stop at
the Kodiak the car rock has incorporated
many other features typical of Skoda and
its VW parent
[Music]
emanuelle mentions Volkswagens modular
transverse engine platform this allows
the various brands within the Volkswagen
group to build their own models based on
this platform for example VW Santi rock
or Seiya to take a range of two
gasoline-powered and three diesel
engines are available for the Quran
without ports from 85 to 140 kilowatts
we tested the two-liter diesel with 110
kilowatts of power with a stick shift it
carried the car up from zero to one
hundred and eight point seven seconds
for the top speed of 196 km/h it'd be
hard to miss the design elements the car
rack has borrowed from the Kodiak no
paternity test needed here the familiar
four-eyed face and Skoda grille dominate
the front as has become the norm in
nearly every segment SCOTUS car rack
features an array of drivers assists and
safety systems predictive pedestrian
protection City emergency brake arc
assist and many others and as is the
case with most of car expenditures these
assists come at an extra cost at least
the driver won't have to deactivate them
when they're not needed
[Music]
at the back led tailights insured good
visibility depending on whether the
seats are up or down the cargo space
ranges from 479 to 1810 liters stowage
space and hooks are an added asset the
car rack seats differ from the Kodiaks
Skoda geared them more toward a younger
target group of buyers the interior has
been kept simple but smart with good
workmanship and fine materials a handy
solution for drinks has been integrated
into the car rack center console studs
in the bottle holders allow occupants to
open and close bottles with only one
hand the optional digital instrument
cluster offers a choice of four
different display modes the 9.2 inch
infotainment system supports gesture
control car rock buyers can choose
between the six-speed manual and the
7-speed dual-clutch automatic
transmission all-wheel drive is
available as an option
[Music]
DeNooyer Amanda will notices the car
rack absorbs road bumps quite nicely as
an SUV it is set higher and the
suspensions a bit softer and with the
all-wheel-drive on this test car it can
go off-road with no problems in the fun
with 18 centimeters of clearance and a
ramp angle of nearly 20 degrees even
rough roads and big chuckles won't stop
it
[Music]
an electronically controlled multi-plate
clutch combines data from various
sources such as the RPMs steering angle
and longitudinal and lateral
acceleration for the optimal
distribution of torque
the man was decided that all in all the
car rock is a success it owes quite a
lot to its big brother the Kodiak
but it's far more compact and that makes
a difference that enhances dynamics
especially in curves and improves the
chances of finding a parking spot the
car rock starts at under twenty four
thousand three hundred euros in Germany
while a Kodiak will cost at least two
thousand more
[Music]
you